Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch,
Donnerstag ... Freitag!
Die Vier-Tage-Woche – mehr freie Zeit.
Mehr Zeit für sich, Freunde,
Familie, Faulenzen …
Und das bei gleichem Gehalt.
Ein Traum, oder?
Und ganz nebenbei rette ich
hier noch die Umwelt! Wie?
Weniger Arbeitsstunden bedeuten weniger
Pendler und damit weniger Verkehr.
Außerdem könnten Büros einen Tag länger
geschlossen bleiben.
Energieverbrauch und Emissionen
werden so reduziert.
Aber mal ehrlich:
Was hindert mich daran,
in meiner neu gewonnenen Freizeit
nicht einfach ausgiebig zu shoppen?
Oder mal eben in den Kurzurlaub zu fliegen?
Außer Corona natürlich …
Können wir unseren CO2-Abdruck durch
mehr Freizeit wirklich senken?
Es lässt sich tatsächlich eine
positive Korrelation beobachten,
zumindest in Europa und Nordamerika,
zwischen Arbeitstagen,
wo mehr emittiert wird,
und Wochenendtagen,
also eher tendenziell freien Tagen,
wo weniger emittiert wird.
Arbeitnehmer, die mehr Zeit haben,
nutzen eher öffentliche Verkehrsmittel
oder das Fahrrad und lassen
das Auto stehen.
Sie essen zum Beispiel auch
weniger Fertiggerichte
und bevorzugen insgesamt
einen nachhaltigeren Lebensstil.
Unternehmen können das unterstützen.
Wie kann man aber auch systemische
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen,
die es Individuen erleichtern,
sich nachhaltig zu verhalten?
Und dazu gehört dann eben vielleicht auch,
die Arbeitszeiten zu verkürzen,
um einerseits die Emissionen aus dem
Pendeln ein bisschen rauszunehmen
und zu senken und andererseits
dafür zu sorgen,
dass wir einfach mehr Zeit
zur Verfügung haben,
um Verhaltensweisen, von denen wir
eigentlich wissen, dass sie nachhaltiger sind,
zu denen wir aber einfach
nicht kommen im Alltag,
auch wirklich realisieren zu können.
Mehr Freizeit muss dabei nicht
weniger Gehalt bedeuten.
Denn eine kürzere Arbeitszeit heißt nicht,
dass wir weniger schaffen.
Im Gegenteil: Zahlreiche Studien
weltweit haben gezeigt,
dass Arbeitnehmer effektiver sind,
sobald die Arbeitszeit gekürzt wird.
Als Microsoft die Vier-Tage-Woche
in Japan getestet hat,
soll die Produktivität
um 40 Prozent angestiegen sein.
Tatsächlich legt auch Forschung nahe,
dass Arbeitszeitverkürzungen auch
produktivitätssteigernd wirken können,
weil die Menschen zum Beispiel erholter sind
und dann mehr Leistung
pro Arbeitszeit bringen können.
Laut Bundesanstalt für
Arbeitsschutz und Arbeitsmedizin
führt eine kürzere Arbeitswoche
zu weniger Stress,
niedrigerem Blutdruck und
weniger Krankheitstagen.
Gleichzeitig sind wir konzentrierter
und produktiver, wenn wir nicht mehr
so lange arbeiten müssen.
Einen Versuch wäre die Vier-Tage-Woche
also wert, oder? Was meint ihr?